david vous avez suivi cette
manifestation parisienne on fait le
compte rendu de cette journée avec vous
et bien écoutez le cortège est parti de
la place de la république à 14h dans le
calme et la bonne humeur encadrés par un
important dispositif de sécurité il faut
le dire environ 5000 policiers étaient
déployés pour encadrer ce traditionnel
défilé du 1er mai le portage est donc
parti vert à 14h15 de la place de la
république est arrivé au milieu du
boulevard voltaire a bien un groupuscule
si vous vouliez de de black blocks
devant le cortège syndical s'en est pris
au mobilier urbain sont est pris aux
banques inquiété au sur le côté est de
la rue du coup les forces de l'ordre
sont intervenues multiples affrontements
ont eu lieu entre forces de l'ordre et
manifestants
mais elle le cortège a pu reprendre son
cours juste après le calme est revenu a
très vite l effort de l'ordre sont
intervenues au total vous l'avez dit 1
34 manifestants ont été arrêtés je me
trouve actuellement avec et olivier
thériault membres de la cgt olivier
thériault si vous deviez faire en mille
ans de ce traditionnel défilé du 1er mai
qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir une forte
mobilisation j'imagine et c'est ça le
plus important
bon une forte mobilisation on avait été
privé de cette fête des travailleurs
l'année dernière donc c'est un bon bilan
parce que on est nombreux
le confinement on a quand même eu
aujourd'hui on voit bien avec la crise
sanitaire
on a quand même appris on a appris aussi
à manifester avec eux que ce soit
d'ailleurs et gilet jaune où les
agressions syndical on peut plus nous
nous brider sur la parole sur le droit
de manifester sous prétexte de deux
crises sanitaires donc déjà ça a été
compliqué de pas de revivre ce qu'on a
vécu l'année dernière sur sur cette
journée qui est une journée très
symbolique après sur sur la façon de
manifester évidemment la colère sociale
elle s'exprime de différentes façons il
n'y a pas que des cortèges syndicaux et
je crois que voilà
peu importe comment ça c'est ça s'est
exprimée en tout cas ça s'exprime le
thermomètre social il est toujours il
est toujours très haut là mais le
mécontentement de la gouvernance il est
tout le temps là
moi je suis à la cgt ratp yahia vraiment
une casse de notre entreprise publique
vers la privatisation qui s'est
accélérée qui continueraient à
s'accélérer dans une période où
justement on a bien vu l'intérêt d'avoir
un service public avec une entreprise de
service public comme l'avait ce slogan
justement quand tout sera privé on sera
privé de tout très symbolique c'était le
message principal aujourd'hui des
travailleurs des organisations
syndicales présentes ici oui tout à fait
c'est
c'est cette période là et montre montre
que justement il ya nécessité à revenir
à des fondamentaux sur le le partage de
ce qui appartient au goût commun et
c'est pas en applaudissant aux fenêtres
ou voilà au juste on rend compte et ce
tant sur des sur les réseaux sociaux
qu'on va changer les choses il faut
aller dans la rue il faut braver ce ces
espèces de couvre-feu qu'on essaie de
nous imposer qu'on est unis tête
il faut aller plus loin dans la
contestation il faut continuer faut pas
avoir peur
faut quand même faire attention à à ses
voisins n'y a pas de souci mais faut
vraiment continuer à contester ce c'est
pas possible on peut pas aller dans le
mur quand on voit que cette période là
là permis à grosses fortunes de
continuer à s'enrichir et à creuser les
écarts sociaux
donc voilà il faut continuer on a aussi
bientôt les régionales nous c'est
important pour nous on voit bien que
pécresse tout toute cette toute cette
frange de politique veut nous prêter nos
services publics et ce qui est assez
intéressant derrière dans la cote c'est
qu'on a aussi beaucoup de d'agents de la
ratp qui sont investis dans les
régionales sur sur des listes alors je
suis pas là pour faire pour faire
converger l'entente représentant
syndical ne vais pas citer deux listes
politiques mais en tout cas il ya un
vrai une vraie prise de conscience de ce
qu'on est en train de faire et voilà si
ce 1er mai justement important de
montrer cette mobilisation conséquente
juste avant ces élections régionales et
puis dans un an les élections
présidentielles montrer à que les
revendications sociales sont toujours
présentes parce que on a l'impression
que d'une certaine manière la crise
sanitaire a pris le pas sur les
questions sociales et sur les réformes
sociales
oui la crise sanitaire elle a eu à
l'oeil bon dos pour essayer de faire
taire toutes ces revendications sauf que
eux
aujourd'hui on est dans le concret et et
les gens de chez eux voient bien ce qui
est en train de se passer
donc il n'y a rien de positif à ce qu'on
est en train de nous présenter pour
l'avenir le monde
demain et encore plus dégueulasse que le
monde donne dans lequel on était avant
cette crise sanitaire
la crise sanitaire elle n'a pas créé
cette situation elle l'a fait
qu'accélérer le processus qui sentirait
de jour en jour donc évidemment que là
que la contestation sociale
elle est au niveau aujourd'hui et c'est
pas anodin si les gens sortent le 1er
mai dans ses prises pendant cette crise
sanitaire
c'est bien que la contestation sociale
allez au niveau elle est légitime et que
les citoyens s'inquiètent pas ce qui est
en train de se passer
donc les enjeux électoraux évidemment il
faudra pas les louper les régionales ici
sont très importantes pour nous à la
ratp sur le service public
mais les autres échéances électorales
aussi ont forcément une incidence sur la
vie des citoyens
donc voila moi je suis très content de
ce premier mais peu importe comment il
puisse se passer peu importe qui sera
contrat moi ce que je note c'est qu'il y
avait beaucoup de monde dans la rue est
vraiment dans une unité pour l'intérêt
l'intérêt de tout le monde que ce soit
les travailleurs les privés d'emploi les
retraités tous ceux qui font qu'il faut
que qui font les vrais citoyens et pas
assez privilégiés dont les symboles ont
été attaqués mais je suis pas pleurer
voilà je vais pas pleurer sur quelques
vitrines de banques péter ils ont des
assurances pour ça ce que je note c'est
que voilà la casse qui a été fait
si c'est là dessus que certains veulent
insister c'est la casse autre king les
politiques même si je suis pas
spécialement fan de la méthode
voilà toutes les contestations sont
bonnes à prendre et en tout cas ce que
je note aussi c'est qu'elles sont toutes
allées dans le même sens c'est la
contester ce qui tue l'avenir pour nous
propose si beaucoup il était heureux
d'avoir répondu à nos questions voilà
vous l'aurez compris en retenir le
message essentiel de cette mobilisation
du 1er mai est ce symbolique manifester
pour les travailleurs c'est avant tout
l'image qu'ils ont voulu en donner
aujourd'hui les organisations syndicales
a réuni lors de cette mobilisation du
1er mai qui touche à sa fin et 6 place
de la nation
si beaucoup david khalifa reprend